always say less than necessary and the
idea is that if you're in a meeting with
people that man or woman who talks less
generally has an aura of power
particularly a boss they seem enigmatic
mysterious and when they do something
say something everybody's hanging on
their words what did that mean but say
whereas people who talk a lot give the
impression that they're weak they signal
weakness they can't control themselves
so they can't control themselves how can
they control anything in the business
world right
so be aware of that you're probably
talking too much in a lot of
circumstances and maybe you can control
that and so this is kind of a way of
defending yourself in an environment
where people will tend to see you as
weak if you can't have any self-control
if you want power in this world if you
are fighting for a cause if you want
some kind of justice you have to be
strategic you have to think like that
you have to think in terms of power
people just don't give themselves up you
have to hit them you have to be strong
you have to be forceful it's a power
game and i can't stand people who are
naive who think that just being
themselves just being virtuous is going
to get what they want in life if you're
going to fight for something you have to
be able to meet the enemy on their terms
of power crush your enemy totally and
understand that in the business world
that law prevails 95 of the time when a
company like google or any tech company
has an enemy their goal is to get rid of
them completely to buy them out so they
have no competitors right look at amazon
but even smaller businesses dealing with
rivals it's a dynamic in the business
world so you need to be aware of it and
not be naive you don't have to practice
it but you need to be aware of it
there's much in life that is way beyond
your control but there's a margin that
you can control right and it's mostly
about your relationships that's to do
with your children
your spouse your partners your
colleagues at work your bosses and the
feeling that you have no control over
them that they can do whatever they want
that you have an idea and you want to
sell it to them or you want somebody to
stop their annoying behavior and you
can't control them is to me the worst
feeling for a human being to have
probably the most important aspect that
i'm forgetting here is power over
yourself
self mastery right because a lot of the
problems that you have in life you can't
really control yourself
you're subject to all these emotions
these moods these things that grab you
that obsess you that possess you your
mind has these recurring thoughts you
have no self-control and it drives you
crazy you have a habit you want to get
rid of you take some program some class
and three months later you're back at it
so the sense that you can control
yourself
to a degree and the sense that you can
have some influence over people is power
and the more you have it the greater the
feeling you have because you can get
avoid that helplessness that makes all
of us kind of crazy what are the ways we
destroy our own power
generally by not having the ability to
adapt to circumstances
you go through life and if you're
successful or have some success you kind
of depend on certain skills certain
strategies that get you where you want
to be and then you find yourself in a
position that's new and circumstances
that are new and you keep doing the same
thing over again and it doesn't work
and you get angry and you get frustrated
you blame other people this guy's not
listening to me this isn't working it's
because you're not adapting right
so you need to have this
it's a kind of a zen
of every circumstance is different you
have to have a sense of flow
every thing that you encounter every
problem is new
what worked in the past won't work again
i need to adapt i need to be able to
flow and be fluid and adaptable
[Music]